liebe mitbürgerinnen und liebe mitbürger
trost und kritik in ihrer
neujahrsansprache trauert die kanzlerin
mit angehörigen von corona opfern
das leugnen des virus nennt sie grausam
und zynisch mächtig selbstbewusst zwölf
monate nach dem chor ohne ausdruck fühlt
sich china wie ein sieger
[Applaus]
willkommen 2021 hoffnungsvoll wie wohl
lange nicht begrüßt die welt das neue
jahr
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen wie schön das sie uns in
diesem letzten tag im jahr begleiten
norbert lehmann ist auch dabei für den
sportteil schwandorf und ein
beispielloses jahr geht zu ende die
kanzlerin spricht von einem historischen
kraftakt es seien schwere zeiten für
unser land und so werde es auch noch
eine ganze weile bleiben wenn die
herrscher über die sechzehnte und aller
voraussicht nach letzte
neujahrsansprache von angela merkel
was für ein jahr so lautet angela
merkels erster satz ein atemloses jahr
jetzt sei zeit auch innezuhalten und zu
trauern
wir dürfen als gesellschaft nicht
vergessen wie viele einen geliebten
menschen verloren haben ohne ihm in den
letzten stunden nah sein zu können
ich kann ihren schmerz nicht lindern
aber ich denke an sie mehr als 33.000
menschen in deutschland haben ihr leben
an oder mit 9 10 verloren dass das virus
trotzdem noch von einigen geleugnet wird
kritisiert die kanzlerin
verschwörungstheorien sind nicht nur
unwahr und gefährlich sie sind auch
zynisch und grausam diesen menschen
gegenüber angela merkel dankt ärztinnen
ärzten pflegekräften und auch allen
anderen nie das land am laufen halten
hoffnung mache ihr der impfstoff
trotzdem blieben die zeiten schwer es
wird noch eine ganze zeit an uns allen
liegen wie wir durch diese pandemie
kommen
der winter ist und bleibt hart sie endet
mit einem rückblick auch auf eigene 15
jahre im amt ich denke ich übertreibe
nicht wenn ich sage nie in den letzten
15 jahren haben wir alle das alte jahr
als so schwer empfunden und nie haben
wir trotz aller sorgen und mancher
skepsis mit so viel hoffnung dem neuen
jahr entgegen gesehen
es war vermutlich angela merkels letzte
neujahrsansprache
nächstes jahr kann sie von zuhause zu
gucken wenn ein neues parlament gewählt
und die nachfolge geklärt ist die
kompletten sieben minuten
neujahrsansprache der bundeskanzlerin
können sie gleich nach und seen oder
jederzeit in der zdf
heute app auch die kanzlerin setzt große
hoffnungen in die impfung bislang haben
die hierzulande mehr als 100 31.000
menschen bekommen und auch am letzten
tag des jahres bleiben die korona zahlen
auf hohem niveau
das robert koch institut meldet
innerhalb eines tages mehr als 32.000
neue infektionen in verbindung mit
kuwait 1982 menschen
allerdings sind in den zahlen wohl immer
noch nachmeldungen der feiertage
enthalten kommenden dienstag beraten
bund und länder wie es nach dem zehnter
januar weitergeht längst mehren sich die
forderungen den shutdown zu verlängern
dafür plädiert zum beispiel saarlands
ministerpräsident tobias hans von der
cdu die regierungschefin von mecklenburg
vorpommern manuela schwesig spd sagte
größere lockerungen seien erst bei
inzidenz werten unter 50 möglich heute
liegt dieser wert noch bei knapp 140
es war genau vor einem jahr die ersten
berichte über eine neue mysteriöse
lungenkrankheit in china die betroffenen
hätten sich auf einem fischmarkt in der
großstadt johann infiziert kurz darauf
erkrankte millionen ganze städte wurden
rigoros abgeriegelt und das virus unter
kontrolle gebracht so erfolgreich dass
chinas wirtschaft in diesem krisenjahr
sogar weiter wächst wie sich peking
jetzt als gewinner präsentiert zeigt ulf
röller die chinesischen 19 uhr
nachrichten beginnen mit einem
leuchtenden peking sowie aus china in
die welt strahlen soll das land in dem
alles anfing feiert sich als corona
sieger das virus scheint im griff für
präsident ski ein triumph des volkes
unter der führung der kommunistischen
partei 2020 war ein außergewöhnliches
jahr die pandemie tauchte plötzlich auf
für uns standen die menschen und ihr
leben an erster stelle mit solidarität
und widerstandsfähigkeit haben wir
unseren monumentalen kampf gegen die
pandemie geschrieben
hier war die neujahrsansprache wird mit
heldengeschichten bebildert da führt das
land einen volkskrieg gegen das virus
kein wort davon dass china zu anfang den
ausbruch verschwieg die schattenseiten
des corona kampfes zeigten damals mutige
bürgerreporter sie finden das chaos in
den krankenhäusern von johann die
meisten von ihnen sind verschwunden die
bürgerreporter passen eben nicht auf das
siegerfoto
da china der welt präsentieren will für
presse denn sie beweist der erfolgreiche
corona kampf die überlegenheit des
autoritären chinesischen systems vor
allem im vergleich zu amerika china ist
in diesem jahr mächtiger geworden nach
außen drittes selbstbewusst auf nach
innen regieren die machthaber mit
eiserner faust
die pandemie hat präsident ski geholfen
seinem traum von der weltspitze näher zu
kommen so eine silvesternacht wie heute
dürften die meisten von uns noch nicht
erlebt haben weitgehend ohne böller
stattdessen versammlungsverbot
alkoholverbot im öffentlichen raum in
einigen bundesländern sogar
ausgangssperren eines allerdings bleibt
wie gehabt das zdf sendet eine silvester
show vom brandenburger tor
natürlich ohne publikum wie die
hauptstadt diesen außergewöhnlichen
jahreswechsel angeht zeigt sylvia
bleßmann kein feuerwerk zur fernseh fete
am brandenburger tor
keine party draußen fürs publikum wie
überall sollen auch die berliner am
abend zu hause bleiben mit der familie
ein bisschen zu hause rumsitzen und ein
bisschen dinner for one gucken und sekt
trinken wir machen jeden
silvesternachmittag ein spaziergang wird
heute wenn man ganz gemütlich zu hause
bleiben vor dem fernseher schlafen um
wecker stellen um halb zwölf und wird
anstoßen die party metropole berlin ist
leer wo sonst zu silvester stets alles
ausgebucht war kommen nur noch
geschäftsreisende und der chef muss
seine wenigen gäste selbst bedienen
hotel ist lea wir haben zwölf zimmer
belegt 17 gäste
wir haben einen frühstücks casting im
restaurant
und weil alles dicht ist bestellen viele
berliner das silvestermenü beim
restaurant um die ecke
diese beiden gastgeber wollten
eigentlich im herbst neu eröffnen mit
dem shutdown kam die idee ein menü zu
kochen ihr silvester angebot hat sechs
gänge und ist heiß begehrt
wir versuchen mit unserem menü eben die
glücksmomente nach hause zu bringen und
den leuten einfach einen zauberhaften
silvesterabend zu gestalten den werden
voraussichtlich viele menschen vorm
fernseher verbringen die gruppe karat
probt schon die große bühne am
brandenburger tor ist weiträumig
abgesperrt und es gibt ein strenges
hygiene konzept für alle mitarbeiter der
diesjährigen produktion willkommen 20 21
willkommen zum jahreswechsel im zdf
und ich frage direkt nach bei den beiden
moderatoren andrea kiewel und johannes b
kerner das ist für euch auch komplett
anders als sonst warum habt ihr
entschieden diese show durchzuziehen
trotz aller bedenken
also erstmal guten abend liebe barbara
abend liebe zuschauerin und liebe
zuschauer das zdf hat entschieden diese
show zu machen weil es eine art gute
tradition ist das neue jahr hier live am
brandenburger tor willkommen zu heißen
natürlich ohne publikum wir haben es
gerade beitrag gehört ohne party aber
mit tollen künstlern sagen wir gleich
noch und es ist nicht nur was schönes in
diesem jahr finde ich mach das auch
extremst mut und hoffnung ja wir sagen
nicht nur willkommen 20 21 wir sagen mit
bedacht auch bis 2020 und nicht etwa auf
wiedersehen und das brandenburger tor
wird erscheinen wie was noch nicht
hatten mit lichtinstallationen also auf
eine art und weise wie sie es zu hause
sicherlich noch nie gesehen haben es
bleibt für alle beteiligten für euch
auch eine herausforderung vor leeren
platz ohne publikum wollte er dafür
stimmung sorgen also allein wenn ich
johannes sehe bin ich schon glücklich
ehrlich war
wir haben tolle tolle künstler alvaro
solar vicky leandros ist bei uns die
höhner giovanni lorenzo und dann zum
aller ersten mal neu bislang barbara
guckt man uns ja beim silvester feiern
zu
so tritt johannes auch zu hause aus bin
ich mir ganz ganz sicher
dieses mal machen wir es umgekehrt
deutschland privat wir schauen mal wie
unsere zuschauer den abend gestalten zu
großen stars zu thomas gottschalk und
vielen anderen und wir wollen ihnen zu
hause auf digitalem wege die hand
reichen in einem jahr in dem es mehr
einsamkeit gibt als sonst möchten wir da
sein möchten wir diese tradition fort
leben lassen und wir freuen uns auf sie
ab 21 45 uhr im zdf
danke euch beiden und alles gute nach
berlin wir drücken die daumen für nachts
auf und kurz vor dem neuen jahr gibt es
quasi in letzter minute auch noch diese
einigung das britische überseegebiet
gibraltar im süden spaniens soll teil
des schengen raums werden
damit wird verhindert dass es dort nach
dem wechsel keine eu außengrenze gibt
rund 15.000 spanier fahren täglich über
die grenze zur arbeit dazu kommen ins
ohne corona jährlich mehrere millionen
türken und gleich zeigen wir ihnen auch
noch wie bunt und fröhlich die
neuseeländer schon das neue jahr begrüßt
haben jetzt aber erst mal der sport
unten aber vierschanzen tournee station
2 in garmisch partenkirchen heute die
qualifikation ohne vorjahressieger mario
slim weg der wegen zahnschmerzen passen
musste gut dagegen lief es für die
deutschen markus eisenbichler und karl
geiger
der sieger von oberstdorf wird mit 132
metern quali fünfter noch etwas besser
markus eisenbichler mit seinem sprung
auf 135,5 meter platz drei trotz
muskulärer probleme wir morgen marokko
conny trockenheit entspannt wirklich
einmal ohne bier rein rutschen und plan
ins bett außerdem sieben weitere
deutsche im finale morgen
obwohl dem norweger krane rüd der
weiteste sprung gelingt auf 143 meter
sieht der slowene lange shack mit 139
metern wegen besserer noten
ich habe olympia viel gegeben und
olympia hat mir viel gegeben das sagte
einst walther tröger einer der
einflussreichsten deutschen
internationalen sport als präsident des
nationalen olympischen komitees und als
ioc ehrenmitglied walther tröger starb
gestern im alter von 91 jahren
1972 münchen träger verhandelt als
bürgermeister des olympischen dorfes mit
palästinensischen terroristen die elf
israelische sportler als geiseln nehmen
die verhandlungen scheitern die geiseln
sterben 1992 wird trüber präsident des
nationalen olympischen komitees sein
traum olympia noch einmal in deutschland
bleibt unerfüllt 2002 die unerwartete
abwahl als präsident klaus steinbach
übernimmt das nok zu seinem neunzigsten
geburtstag sieht trüge die spiele die
kommen noch ausrichter städte finden in
der krise glaubt dennoch an olympia
zukunft dafür trotz all den technischen
entwicklungen und all dem so bleiben
dass die die menschheit und die jungen
leute vor allem sind miteinander messen
wollen die nächsten spiele in tokio
werden die ersten seit mehr als 50
jahren ohne walther tröger sein
ja das ist traurig habe aber auch etwas
fertiges beide aus der welt des sports
formel-1-weltmeister lewis hamilton darf
sich nämlich lösen denn die queen
schlägt ihn zum retter große ehre große
freude sicher auch und freude macht auch
der blick auf die andere seite der welt
denn die neuseser mehr haben die
pandemie ziemlich im griff und konnten
entsprechend ausgelassen das neue jahr
begrüßen axel com hat
die neuseeländer sind wieder unter den
ersten das ist wie jedes jahr
und hier ist ja eigentlich fast alles
wie jedes jahr keine corona fälle mehr
seit einem monat im inselstaat also auch
keine auflagen beim feiern ganz anders
australien das feuerwerk auf der harbour
bridge in sydney deutlich kürzer
deutlich abgespeckt party im hafen
viertel bei strafe verboten pandemie
silvester ausnahme silvester es ist ein
seltsames neuer normalerweise ist es
hier voller leute irgendwie ist das
unheimlich aber wir werden das neue jahr
begrüßen und dann ist auch china daran
woran da wo alles anfing vor genau einem
jahr jetzt menschen dichtgedrängt party
ohne schlechtes gewissen beste laune
ich wünsche mir für 20 21 dass alle gut
auf ihre gesundheit aufpassen freunde
und familie gesund bleiben und gutes
gelingen in allen dingen von party
können wir in europa noch nur träumen
aber schön aussehen kann sylvester ja
trotzdem sowie im schottischen edinburgh
proben für die große silvester thronen
show geräusch und emissionsarm und auch
als online event 20 21 muss einfach
besser werden in diesem sinne danken wir
ihnen sehr herzlich für ihr großes
interesse und ihrem zuspruch in diesem
jahr das gesamte heute team wünscht
ihnen nur das beste für 2021 bleiben sie
gesund und uns gewogen
eines sollten sie noch wissen es kommt
nämlich schnee aus dem südwesten und
damit auch rutschgefahr die details zum
wetter hat gleich osten terli alles gute
ihnen und bis morgen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]